one of the most common traumas that
people are going to go through is
heartbreak you're going to be in a
relationship that you imagine is going
to continue forever maybe when you're 18
or sometimes when you're 48 then it's
going to stop have you thought about the
Neuroscience of what's happening during
heartbreak what's happened is the person
is no longer available in time and space
this is why when someone breaks up you
literally have to let them go constant
pursuing of them is out of context is
not healthy they have a name for that
it's called a stalker don't do it the
brain has to think that the person is
gone in time and space this has become
much harder with social media because
people can check up on people they can
hear from people in the old days like
when I was growing up you just like took
the phone off the hook or you've
diverted your attention now we are
constantly renewing that the person is
still there a loss of love and the death
grief are virtually identical and this
is why it's so hard to not reach out to
somebody that you really miss and want
back